[Aplausos]
é um grande desafio estar aqui hoje com
vocês
a gente vê hoje estudantes aqui
professores empresários e entusiastas
com certeza a gente daqui da cidade
gente de outras cidades o pessoal do
youtube e assistindo a gente pela
internet e uma das primeiras coisas que
eu pensei quando eu comecei a me
preparar para estar aqui neste momento
foi será que todo mundo vai concordar
comigo será que eu vou agradar a todo
mundo
eu queria ver com vocês se vocês também
têm esse mesmo tipo de pensamento
eu quero ouvir vocês key já esteve na
situação em que ficou com medo de
discordar de alguém falar alguma opinião
que era contrária a uma outra pessoa
levantei a mão que já teve a situação
bem acredito que todo mundo 100% em
algum momento da vida teve nessa
situação pode ter sido que nessa
situação você tenha superado esse medo
em falar da opinião assim mesmo e talvez
pedido amizade ou pior pode ter sido que
nessa situação que pode ser da internet
também não precisa ser ao vivo você tem
evitado de falar sua própria opinião
porque você teve medo de magoar outra
pessoa
infelizmente todos nós devemos é esse
tipo de situação desde pequenos
desde pequenos nós temos as nossas
opiniões e temos medo de expressá-la
seja porque a gente tem medo da briga
numa situação em que beleza é
simplesmente uma discussão ou
simplesmente porque você não não sabe
como falar que não quer se expressar e
têm receio de que aquela opinião possa
tachá lo de alguma forma eu vou contar
pra vocês uma história que tem a ver com
esse medo e eu quero que vocês imaginem
o que acontece nessa história
então imaginem uma garota que não tem
problema nenhum de falar
seja um grupo pequeno seja um grupo
grande
uma garota que é professora e que sempre
tem explicação pra qualquer coisa na
ponta da língua
por isso mesmo a sala de aula ela não
tem problema nenhum mas nenhum de
argumentar
então ela tem opinião ela sabe como essa
opinião e ela se expressa bem esse não é
o problema pra ela
agora imaginem essa mesma garota em uma
mesa de bar com os amigos uma conversa
normal todo mundo ali se divertindo
quando entra um tópico ali mais polêmico
as pessoas começam a ficar mais
exaltadas os ânimos mais animados a voz
começa a subir começa a discussão começa
o argumento aqui a vai pra mim
a conversa não acabe vai-vai essa garota
vai ficar ansiosa ansiosa preocupada
irritada com a situação ela para tudo
para aquela conversa e perguntaram tá
frio hoje né fala qualquer coisa
qualquer coisa simplesmente para
apaziguar aquela discussão
essa garota sou eu
ou melhor essa garota era eu porque eu
via qualquer conflito como algo negativo
eu tinha uma necessidade pessoal de
apaziguar aquele conflito de evitar
discórdia
esse era meu objetivo de vida nada de
discórdia isso engraçado falar isso
quando eu estava no meio de uma
discussão e aí que vem a contradição no
meio de uma discussão porque quando
estava a situação em que eu tinha o
controle da palavra como nesse momento
aqui e que vos fala
eu não tenho problema nenhum nunca tive
e nem na sala de aula em que eu ali como
professora dominava a palavra e o
problema é exatamente aí quando eu
percebi na sala de aula que conhece esse
tipo de atitude estava impedindo os meus
alunos desenvolver um pensamento crítico
porque a partir do momento que na sala
de aula que existe amor
logo como é que os alunos vão conectar
tudo que eu apresento como professora e
vão realmente pensar criticamente sobre
aquilo com essa reflexão e com essa
indagação eu comecei a pensar se nossa
gente não quer isso nem a sala de aula e
muito menos fora da sala de aula
pessoas que não têm um pensamento
crítico e algum professor estava
deixando de ter o meu papel em
desenvolver essa habilidade fazendo esse
tipo de monólogo
foi aí que eu comecei a ficar curiosa
sobre mediação de conflitos sobre o
debate
comecei a pesquisar sobre o assunto
comecei a pesquisar especial sobre
diálogos argumentativos e essa pesquisa
me levou aos debates competitivos
vocês devem conhecer o que é baixo
porque a gente já viu vários debates
políticos e outros tipos de baixo mas
talvez vocês não conheçam o que é debate
competitivo para explicar para vocês eu
vou falar de um exemplo de modelo de
debate porque existem vários que o nosso
grupo
o argumento e desenvolve nas competições
que nós organizados neste modelo
nós temos dois times de três pessoas
cada
cada pessoa do time tem seu momento de
fala e nesse momento esse momento de
falar é cronometrado
essa pessoa à medida que vai alternando
entre um time e outro também tem um
momento de perguntas essas perguntas tem
que ser com cinzas e direto ao ponto as
respostas também tudo tudo cronometrado
além disso nós temos os juízes que
avaliam a construção do argumento e da
planta argumentação e são eles que
definem que o time vencedor
mas aí vocês podem me perguntar se eu
estava mas isso não gera brilha
eu vou dizer pra vocês que existe um
tubo lugar não gera briga porque a faa a
posição do time tinha a favor do time
contra é sorteada com esse sorteio que
acontece a opinião pessoal daquela
pessoa que está debatendo é protegida
então o debate ele acaba ficando única e
exclusivamente no conteúdo no tema e não
um ataque pessoal sempre entre os que
estão debatendo
dessa forma a gente tem que as pessoas
não só porque já é um jogo em que as
regras dizem claramente que deveria se
basear puramente não tem na argumentação
mas também porque ele não sabe mesmo o
que o outro pensa não adianta você
atacar outros você nem sabe que aqui um
pensamento da pessoa e eu vou dizer pra
vocês depois que eu comecei a trabalhar
num debate competitivo que eu comecei a
participar ea desenvolver alguns debates
é um passei a me divertir absurdamente
nas discussões em que eu participei
depois disso a gente tem então que um
debate ele permite que a pessoa acaba
pensando como o outro porque como eu
falei
talvez você acaba acaba tendo que
defender uma opinião que não é a sua ou
mesmo que você deve fazer sua própria
opinião você precisa contar bonita então
você precisa pensar com o outro para
prosseguir contra argumentar isso faz
com que você tenha essa empatia muito
desenvolvida e esse aprofundamento no
conteúdo por exemplo uma situação que
aconteceu uma vez nós organizamos um
debate é um debate entre universitários
e um dos chineses acabou revelando logo
depois do sorteio que na verdade eles
eram contrários ao tema quando foram
sorteados para defenderem o tempo claro
que eles estavam desesperados falando-se
nossa como assim a gente vai ter que
defender um tema que a gente diz
acredita ele inclusive tinha participado
de uma assembléia na própria
universidade desacreditando aquele tema
só que aconteceu eles tinham duas opções
poderiam simplesmente
e porque afinal de contas poderiam ir lá
defendeu o que eles acreditavam de
qualquer forma entender o que foi que
eles escolheram fazer eles poderão se
aprofundar no tema e ali no papel de
batedor debater como pessoa que é a
favor daquele tempo porque eles fizeram
possíveis ganharam aquela rodada e
depois dessa rodada de debates
eles chegaram pra mim falar assim ler
quer saber de uma coisa
a gente se convenceu eles acabaram
mudando de idéia com os próprios
argumentos o que aconteceu ali não é que
a só porque eu tive que defender eu
passei a acreditar naquilo não é isso é
que antes eles estavam tão enviesado
citam de um lado só sem pensar um outro
lado que nem perceber o que na verdade e
acreditar no outro lado ele uma maioria
maioria pensava de um lado eles iam
naquele naquela mas nada demais nessa
mesma competição ao longo do dia 5 um
dia de competição todos os grupos cada
vez mais se mostravam mais e mais e mais
e mais à vontade em debater mas não era
só durante a competição eles continuaram
debatendo em todos os intervalos a gente
no corredor norte cujo estavam
discutindo qual o resultado ele estava
debatendo em geral era sobre o mesmo
tempo que ele já tinha acabado de
discutir só que na opinião deles e aí
fora
o que acontecia é que eles ali se
sentiam à vontade em debater porque eles
sabiam que ali todo mundo era
problemático
então eles conseguiram se libertar das
amarras sociais que a gente acaba tendo
nas outras situações em discutir
abertamente
então o que eu posso dizer pra vocês é
que o debate acaba gerando empatia ele
acaba gerando uma reflexão e um
aprofundamento sobre o tema e melhora a
capacidade de expressão e público
daquelas pessoas elas passam a falar
melhor o público
mas vocês podem me dizer tal é legal eo
que eu tenho a ver com isso
talvez eu nunca participei de uma
competição universitária e tudo que você
me fala é de competição adversário
eu posso dizer pra vocês que vocês podem
levar o debate para o dia a dia de vocês
levem o debate para suas rodas de amigos
leve um de baixo preço o seu próximo
almoço de família e vai ter aquela
confusão gente falando tudo de lado
faça um pequeno debate ou pelo menos
organize melhor as suas discussões e eu
vou dar pra vocês cinco dicas que vão
facilitar esse processo
a primeira delas é respeite quanto usar
um tom de voz não usar caso não use tom
de voz de ironia
não use tom de voz de raiva não tente
ameaça outra pessoa mesmo que de forma
sutil do tipo eu sou sua mãe não falha
foi comigo não faça isso não faça isso
porque quando você demonstra calma
segurança e respeito à outra pessoa tem
muito mais chance de perceber e entender
o que você vai passar do que se você
tenta usar drama csi a primeira coisa ou
se esclareça
mas ouça de verdade
não adianta você começar outra pessoa
está falando e fala assim eu sei eu sei
o que você quer dizer já entende eu sei
como você pensa não faça isso
ouça entendo qual ponto de vista da
pessoa
se não estiver claro que a pessoa falou
não que você interpreta do que a pessoa
falou
pergunte a mim pergunte para que todos
entendam qual é o ponto de vista de cada
um e que fique claro que fico que fique
objetivo que não seja simplesmente uma
roda de pré conceitos sobre como cada um
pensa
a terceira dica é argumente contra a
doente por não falar mente eu me refiro
ato desenho conclusões que sejam
justificadas e que sejam fundamentadas
em fatos não 11 11 fontes que não sejam
confiáveis
não adianta essa história de chegar
assim a linha um lugar na internet
então eu acho assim não gente se informe
a discutir sobre o assunto fala sobre o
que você sabe tudo bem às vezes a gente
faz uma diferença de uma coisa ou outra
mas deixa claro se esse for o caso na
medida do possível tente se informar o
máximo
não tente usar dados de uma forma
incompleta só para conseguir ganhar um
argumento né
é como a gente fazer porque a gente não
quer perder então não tente fazer isso é
melhor manter sua integridade ea pessoa
depois de checar e saber que você falou
a verdade sem ficar tuitando nipo aquele
dado do que o contrário e
contra-argumentar significa você fazer o
mesmo processo de conclusão com
justificativa fundamentada mais
contrário outra pessoa falou
faça tudo isso ainda com respeito a dica
número 1
dica número 4 observe observe o seu meio
observe o contexto daquele de baixo
se por acaso você observa que
primeiramente ninguém ou alguém não
falou ao a uma pessoa que não tenha
falado que a pessoa falar
será que a pessoa não não falou porque
não têm uma opinião naquele assunto é
muito pouco provável ou porque a pessoa
não se sentiu à vontade em falar não
achou que era convidado a falar do messi
com vídeo a pessoa assim que você pensa
sobre esse assunto qual a sua opinião
convide a pessoa observe também se vocês
não estão circulando circulando
circulando em cima do mesmo argumento o
ato alguma coisa outra fala outra coisa
o primeiro lado repete segundo lado
repete o terceiro lado repete o quadro
se repete que isso leva ninguém a lugar
nenhum
se isso está acontecendo deixa aquele
argumento de lado passe para o próximo e
observe também se a conversa não virou
briga
se a conversa começa a caminhar para uma
melhor para melhor não perder a amizade
porque a cultura de debate para que ela
se torne positiva e para que ela seja
comum nas nossas vidas
exige um trabalho lento e um trabalho
que não é feito em uma roda de conversa
não tenha paciência não deu certo
debater discutir naquele momento outro
dia vocês conversam
o problema última dica conscientize a si
próprio e ao outro porque o objetivo do
debate não é a mudança de opinião
isso pode até acontecer mas não
necessariamente você tem que ver como
objetivo do debate é a mudança de
opinião o debate ele tem como objetivo
que as pessoas entendam os pontos de
vistas pontos de vista um do outro e que
passem a ter um maior empatia em relação
a como um outro peso e mais o objetivo
do debate é uma construção coletiva do
conhecimento para que a gente chegue a
soluções melhores no futuro
o que eu posso dizer pra vocês aqui com
essas cinco dicas vocês podem ter um
poder transformador do das próximas
discussões que vocês tenham na vida de
vocês com os familiares e os amigos que
pode ajudar muito a construir uma
comunidade muito melhor e essa essa esse
poder transformador ele não precisa se
limitar às competições como eu falei
antes de universitários e não precisa se
limitar às rodas de de amigos elas podem
ir além
podem para as escolas nas escolas nós
podemos fazer de bairros entre salas de
aula uma sala de aula uma só disciplina
interdisciplinar entre colégio são
inúmeras formas tanto de fazer o debate
em mudança de forma quanto tempo nas
empresas a gente dá pra usar debate
competitivo na empresa
imagina aquele tema polêmico por exemplo
jornada de trabalho tem que ser de 85 ou
de vencer seis horas de trabalho por dia
o que é melhor trabalho em casa ou
trabalho trabalho de casa alguns dias ou
não todo dia tem que ser a empresa é por
exemplo a essência
paternidade/maternidade deveria ser
compartilhada na empresa ou não vamos
manter só do jeito que é
tradicionalmente somente a mulher tantos
meses e assim vai
então qualquer tema polêmico em que
muitas vezes colocar que intensa de um
lado de outro pode trazer problemas para
aquela pessoa é melhor fazer um debate
competitivo você designa os lados
aleatoriamente coloca as pessoas para
discutir
quero saber o que ela tem que assumir
aquele papel é propõe possíveis soluções
e depois ver quais as soluções são
viáveis
além das empresas e das escolas você
pode trabalhar também com o debate nas
comunidades da mesma forma tem um
problema quer que o problema se foque no
conteúdo na solução e não em quem fala o
uso de baixo competitivo designa os
lados aleatoriamente
eu vim aqui para falar com vocês hoje
porque eu acredito muito no debate como
essa ponte entre hoje e um futuro em que
dialogar seja algo natural e o debate
seja algo simples de se fazer no dia a
dia
eu espero que um dia nós possamos usar o
debate e que eu possa dizer ah eu
organizo debate sem brigas sem usar a
palavra sem briga porque hoje em dia é
assim que eu tenho que definir quando eu
falar e organiza debates que são sem
brilho eu quero usasse a palavra sempre
porque a palavra debate vai ter uma
conotação positiva
eu vou poder dizer eu mesmo debate e
todo mundo vai entender que debates são
sem briga
eu espero ainda que um dia nós possamos
construir mais soluções coletivas para
os nossos problemas através do debate e
que nós tenhamos menos problemas porque
temos mais empatia
hoje com essa conversa e com o trabalho
duro pela frente
eu espero que eu e vocês e nossa futura
gerações possamos todos simplesmente
debater
obrigado
[Aplausos]